but let's talk about it because it's
your new Netflix series it's called beef
tell everybody what it's about like kind
of in a synopsis okay so beef is about
these two strangers it's me and Steven
young so good and we get into a road
rage incident and then we become
obsessed with each other and our lives
start to unravel and um gosh I can't say
enough about what a great guy he is I
think most people probably know him from
The Walking Dead He's Glenn yeah and
it's cool because in this show he gets
to show a lot of his like comedic shops
he's such a funny person and hilarious
but I think what's great about both of
you is you Encompass like
every emotional state like their sadness
there's anger and like even having some
even having that person to just take it
out all on like you know I'm saying it's
obviously not that person it's
everything else going on around it but I
think a lot of people relate to that do
you relate to the character at all I do
relate to the character and I think just
like
her like her having this not feeling she
has a space to be angry or to be ugly I
think a lot of women yeah relate to that
when he came at you about that gratitude
Journal oh yeah it's okay pick your
moment and like it's like it's a
gratitude Journal is great that's great
but like when someone doesn't want to
hear about it is when they're drowning
yes I have like my husband in the show
is a super positive guy and he's so
positive and my character tries to like
uh really vent to him and he kind of
shuts it down yeah and this very like
positive way but it's still shut down
yeah you know and so
yeah so I think everyone's had that
where you're like oh no no no I really
it took forever for me to even voice
this exactly and now I'm voicing it and
you just shut it down that's super fun
yeah and it's also like that and
unleashing
um and like venting and is also a form
of intimacy and so when he shuts her
down it's like oh you don't want to go
there with me yeah you know like this is
a very for us because it's essentially
yes guys opening up yeah and yet guys in
it is like oh I love you I want the best
friend it's like well then be a part of
this with me right it's it's really
interesting the relationships in it the
just anger in it of like of just how
life happens and it's not perfect and
and carrying the weight of everything oh
my God that one point and your
mother-in-law oh my oh yeah
she does such a great job of being
unlikable
I love it it's such a great show if you
haven't seen it guys oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
I'm going
[Music]